good evening from the high court in
Pretoria where Oscar Pistorius has faced
his first day on trial for the
premeditated murder of his girlfriend
reeva Steenkamp it was in the early
hours of Valentine's Day last year that
Oscar Pistorius shot Riva thinking
historias maintains that she was an
intruder hiding inside his bathroom
throughout the trial we're going to be
bringing you the key exchanges between
the prosecution and defense lawyers and
the testimony of the key witnesses well
this morning
Rivas mother June Steenkamp was one of
the first to arrive not answering
reporters questions but insisting that
she just wanted the opportunity to
really look Oscar in the eyes in her
words then Oscar Pistorius himself a
huge scrum of media interest around in
the seat walked into the court building
followed by cameras reporters and on
lookers proceedings finally got underway
after quite a delay this morning the
judge Z leis masipa presiding over the
court apologized for what she called a
bit of a hiccup as with all trials here
in South Africa there is no jury just
two Assessors will help the judge decide
Pistorius is guilt or innocence
proceedings began with the state laying
out the murder charge against Pistorius
on a number of other firearms charges
the first count against each accused
count one is one of murder accused it
unlawfully and intentionally kill a
person to wit reeva Steenkamp a 29 year
old SEMA
they discount one that can't work yes
do you understand the charges mr.
Pistorius I do I do milady how do you
plead not guilty milady account number
two in that the accused is guilty of the
face of contravention on or about 30
September 2012 and whilst driving in a
vehicle with other passengers on a
public road at linear motor 14 in the
district of Kempton Park they used it
unlawfully discharged a firearm without
good reason to do so by firing a shot
with his own 9-millimeter pistol through
the open Sun roof of the car they were
travelling in how do you plead not
guilty milady count three and attaches
restaurant Melrose Arch in a district of
Janice burg the accused unlawfully
discharged a firearm to wit a Glock 27
pistol without any good reason to do sir
how do you plead not guilty milady and
then finally count for the accused that
unlawfully have in his possession
ammunition - it 38.3 eight rounds
without being the holder of a license in
respect of the farm capable of
discharging the ammunition the permit to
possess ammunition see a dealer's
license manufacturers license gunsmith
license import/export or in transit
permit where transporters permit issued
in terms of the act or D or is otherwise
authorized to do sir
do you understand count for RT milady
how do you plead not guilty milady
next defense lawyer carry old Varga had
the opportunity to present pistorius's
opening statement in which he
categorically rejected the allegation
that he shot River intentionally the
state has contended the by unlawfully
and intentionally killed three versus
the income the selig ation is denied in
the strongest terms in fact at the time
of the tragic accident which led to
Rivas death we were in a loving
relationship whilst I admit that I
inflicted the fatal gunshot wounds to
Riva this occurrence was indeed an
accident in that I had mistakenly
believed that an intruder or intruders
had entered my home and posed an
imminent threat to River and me
during the early hours of the morning I
brought two fans in from the balcony I'd
certainly before spoken to Riva who was
in bed beside unbeknown to me
Arriva must have gone to the toilet in
the bathroom at the time when I brought
the fans brought in the fans closed the
sliding doors and drew the blinds and
curtains
I heard the bathroom window sliding open
I believe that an intruder or intruders
had entered the bathroom through the
bathroom window which was not fitted
with burglar bars I approached the
bathroom armed with my firearm so as to
defend Reba and I at that time I believe
Reba was still in the bed the
discharging of my firearm was
precipitated by a noise in the toilet
which I in my fearful state knowing that
I was on my stumps unable to run away or
properly defend myself physically
believed to be the intruder or intruders
coming out of the toilet to attack Reva
and me at my bail application
state inter alia contended that I
deliberately shot Reba whilst I was
positioned at a distance of about 1.5
meters from the toilet door whilst I was
standing on mice prosthesis the
allegation with reference to 1.5 meters
and me wearing my prosthesis was clearly
designed to suggest that I had pursued
Riva to the toilet and I therefore knew
Riva was in the toilet thus that I did
not entertain any fear at a time when it
is a lady that I entered the bathroom
the state is also by means of the
evidence of the then investigating
officer Hilton Berta sought to rely on a
statement by a witness who I am told is
a certainly stephan america who claims
to have heard what sounded like a
woman's voice prior to the shooting
talking nonstop and like fighting
thunder Mademoiselle is located
approximately 105 meters from my bedroom
with my bedroom and bathroom windows
facing in the opposite direction to find
America's house it would not have been
possible for Thunder matter to have
heard anyone talking from my bedroom in
their bedroom now a legend
in the further particulars provided that
there was in fact an argument between
Reeve and I and that I killed River in
quotes because of the argument I deny
this allegation and reiterate that there
is no justification whether legally or
factually for this unfair and incorrect
allegation to have been made the state
has now conceded that it cannot be
contended as a fact I was about 1.5
meters from the toilet door and that I
had my prosthesis attached at the time
when I discharged the firearm any more
the unfair approach adopted by the state
is further evident from the evidence
given by Hilton Witter the bail
application whose evidence will be
demonstrated to have been false in
material respects more particularly that
it was designed to falsely incriminate
me on an allegation of premeditated
murder
it will also be demonstrated during the
strop whilst booth was the investigating
officer and tasked with preserving the
scene that the scene was contaminated
disturbed and tampered with
I've been led to understand it is
unusual to challenge the state's case in
my plea explanation to the extent that I
do here in however I am left with no
alternative but to explain my innocence
with reference to the allegations
leveled against me as the state is aware
of the fact that it has no evidence to
prove an alleged argument and in
particular in view of the fact that the
state is conceded that it does not know
what the features or import of such
alleged argument would have been the
only intended purpose of an attempt to
introducing admissible character
evidence would be to engineer and bring
about an inadmissible attempted
assassination of my character that no
truthful evidence can never be tendered
that I fired the shots and I quote
because of the argument unquote I deny
this allegation in the strongest terms
because there was no argument the
allegation that I wanted to shoot
brackets or kill close brackets Riva
cannot be further from the truth well
watch it all unfold from the front row
of the media benches inside the court
our correspondent hides Crawford's a bit
about the atmosphere in there well quite
the electric active food to begin with
apart from the fact that we had one and
a half hour delay at the beginning but
everyone arrived very full of tension
you could feel the tension in the room
and then we waited and we waited when we
wait and slowly that tension dissipated
and then it became a little bit farcical
because the the interpreter wasn't able
to be found and then when she turned up
it became evident that the first witness
spoke better English than the
interpreter but you've got a real sense
of how much stronger the Pistorius team
was I thought I mean compared to the
last time Oscar Pistorius appeared
before the court at his bail application
hearing he was a mess and so was his
family he spent most of the time
absolutely sobbing had to be told
repeatedly by the magistrate to pull
himself together he was a broken man
then he looked awful he sounded terrible
and he could not stop crying
his family were also spent a lot of the
time crying his brother and his sister
holding hands praying crying this time
the family were much more strong they
appeared much more confident Oscar
Pistorius himself came with a huge April
powder paper took copious notes the
whole time had a briefcase full of paper
spent a lot of the time talking to his
legal team and occasionally referring to
his his family but he was very very
composed this time and that first
witness I we got a real sense we're
going to be hearing more in a moment got
a real sense of the trauma of that
fateful night my lady just after 3:00 I
woke up from a woman's terrible screams
my monitor backed bucket reward money
colour
i sat upright in bed and my husband also
woke up from the streams her evidence
was at utterly gripping very compelling
evidence she was you couldn't see her
but she was a player Lee Jung Gish woman
I wouldn't say old wouldn't say young
sir a middle-aged maybe a long hair she
came over as a very concerned empathetic
human being she had a furrowed brow
through much of her testimony she was
very nervous and she talked talked about
the trauma of that night and it that
really came through Alex thanks very
much for that Alex back in court all
through this trial of course and after
the break we got to be hearing that
dramatic testimony from the first
witness in the Pistorius trial
welcome back to Pretoria where Oscar
Pistorius has faced his first day of the
court that will decide whether or not
he's guilty of the premeditated murder
of his girlfriend reeva Steenkamp after
opening statements for both the state
prosecutor and Pistorius his defense
team the first witness in this case was
called she was Michelle Berger a
neighbor of pistorius's on his exclusive
estate in Pretoria
she lived just 170 metres away from his
home and she described how she heard
screams and gunshots on that fateful
night a Reavers death Paul Harrison
reports on her testimony of Kenya miss
dear captain microphone art on the
witness stand speaking in her mother
tongue Afrikaans and choosing not to
give evidence on camera university
lecturer Michelle Berger was the first
of a hundred and seven witnesses the
home she shared with her husband a
hundred and seventy seven metres from
the scene of the shooting Yellin ignored
three my lady just after three I woke up
from a woman's terrible screams i sat
upright in bed and my husband also woke
up from the streams my husband jumped up
and went to the balcony I was still
sitting in the bed and I heard her
screams she's being terribly and she
yelled for help they not also heard a
man screaming for help and he three
times he yelled for help my husband
talked on the phone and explained to the
security that they are people next door
being attacked and that they should go
then I was still sitting in bed I heard
his screams again it was worse it was
more intense prosecutor Gerry nel the
man looking to put Oscar Pistorius
behind bars was keen to be clear about
the number of shots fired by Pistorius
on Valentine's Day last year there were
four shots you you said the third could
you perhaps give us a demonstration by
using bump bang
bang bang bang there was a carotid
boozer it was a longer pause between
number one and two than between number
two and three and three and four then I
told my husband that I do not hope that
that woman saw her husband being shot in
front of her because after he screamed
for help we did not hear him again it
was very traumatic for me you could hear
that it was blood-curdling screams and
it leaves you called UConn translator in
work the anxiousness in her voice in the
and fear I started working and then
later on my husband called me he asked
me if I could remember what happened the
previous night and I said yes he then
told me that at the office he just heard
that mr. Oscar Pistorius is on the news
and he thought that there was an
intruder and then he shot his girlfriend
I told my husband that it cannot be
because it's not what we heard clearly
chosen by the prosecution because she
contradicts the Olympic athletes version
of events the exchanges between the
neighbor and Pistorius his defense team
were always going to be fiery that you
stand there believing that Oscar
Pistorius lies and that he lied at the
binary cash I cannot understand why mr.
Pistorius did not hear the screams of a
woman and if he did not hear the screams
of the women that is what that's
equation that needs to be Austrey mr.
Pistorius good therapy shots fired
before you woke up I could feast with
the who I heard four gunshots after I
woke up madam what was my question
because I think that there's some
misunderstanding between us what was my
question can you remember it at all
the question is repeatedly about when I
heard the shots fired I'm not letting
you off Duke I'm coming back to my
question that you have not answered five
times as pistorius's defense lawyer
Barry Roux pushed harder so language
became an issue
Michelle Berger switched to English to
make her strength of feeling clear
m'lady I'd like to explain this in
English the events of that evening was
extremely traumatic for me the fear in
that woman's voice is difficult to
explain to the court I was traumatized
through what I heard that evening so
obviously I didn't go to bed without any
as usual and just carry on it was a very
emotional situation to have to hear the
absolute petrified screams and shouts it
wasn't just another evening it was
extremely emotional m'lady I didn't sit
there with a stopwatch and type down the
timing of each shot I did not sit there
and write down with each shot when she
shouted well I can portray to the court
is that they were foregone gunshots and
that I heard of petrified screaming
sometime during the gunshots and just
after the gunshots was the last that I
heard the same woman's voice the same
woman's voice that woke me that evening
it's quite clear from your version you
are not sure and what you know doing
your dad thing you speculating you're
trying to close all the gaps
your statement contradicts what you say
in corner after questioning why the
witness had slept after such a traumatic
experience Barry Ruth and suggested
Michelle Berger might have mistaken
pistorius's voice for reeva Steenkamp
boys many pictures it sounds like a
woman screaming and what I put to you
that's what would explain why you were
here
like a woman screaming and you also get
a man scream not only a woman the lady
why I'm definitely certain it was two
different people it's because I can
compare the help of the first person and
the second person and the first person
was definitely a female and the shouting
was with that voice I could hear it was
her voice shouting and screaming
fearfully you did not even hear someone
hitting the door so hard with the
cricket bat that it breaks you did not
even hear that the lady I'm sure
gunshots will be louder than a cricket
bat on a door in your mind you put one
on one to get in your sight mr.
Pistorius shot his girlfriend he thought
there was someone trying to break in
there not make sense with what I heard
because the fear in that woman's voice
you only feel like that if your life is
threatened that woman I never doubted
her life was threatened so the end of
day one and the first witness and
already a day packed with drama even
though it was a foreshortened day that
speak to Marty Brandt our crime
correspondent and so Ellen Kalu's who's
a leading South African lawyers been
guiding us through the events here
Barton they said it was going to be the
trial of the century here in South
Africa and it's already proved pretty
dramatic it certainly has we've all
traveled a long way to this and we
haven't been disappointed we were
promised drama and we've got it almost
from
the moment it began apart from that
errand a half delay but we're used to
that in UK courts but we had the
dramatic please for the first time we
heard Oscar Pistorius saying not guilty
in a very polite way
do you understand count for I do my lady
how do you plead not guilty melodia we
had the defense explaining why he was
putting forward that not guilty plea
saying that the prosecution story didn't
stack up and then what have we have we
had the prosecution we were expecting an
opening statement that almost didn't
happen the judge had to remind the
prosecutor that he was expected to say a
few words so he did and what did he talk
about the direct intention to kill so
that was the start that took us through
the first hour or so and then of course
we had the first prosecution witness
Michel Berger and how dramatic that
evidence proved so she said her fee she
said she heard screams then gunshots
then more women screams then of course
she the defense lawyer tried to pick her
apart as the afternoon went on but she
stuck to her guns
the defense saying no you didn't hear a
woman screaming you were probably asleep
when the gunshots gunshots went off what
you heard was Oscar Pistorius batting
down the toilet door with a cricket bat
have you ever heard a cricket bat
hitting the door she said no so the
defence law began I think to unpick what
she was saying but at the end of the day
she stuck to her story thus far I'm
happy to suggest from my side I think
she's quite a credible witness the
defense didn't didn't sway in any way
whatsoever there's one or two question
that needs to be clarified hopefully
that will be done so in tomorrow morning
and in the examination because the state
will have a second bite of the cherry -
obviously enlighten the court with
regard to those aspects and one will
have to see how that turns out also of
concern to me was and we could 13 ELLs
approaches the prosecutor prosecutor I
thought he would have intervened but
earlier maybe to stop very roof from
during in quotation marks the witness
intervenors say but listen this is my
witness be careful not to overdo it
overstep the boundaries but then again
that's cross-examination one must get to
the gist in the bottom line and the the
truth three aren't destroyed Ellen
Martin thank you very much indeed so a
dramatic first day in court with Oscar
Pistorius on trial for the premeditated
murder of his girlfriend reeva Steenkamp
prosecution and defense laying down
their sides of the story the prosecution
says premeditated murder
the defense say it was just a terrible
accident where he had more tomorrow but
of course the most dramatic scene of all
perhaps was the departure of Oscar
Pistorius leaving the court late this
afternoon chased by dozens and dozens of
cameras from around the world as the
world's media looked on at this murder
trial in South Africa
you